derrière ces murs il n'y a plus personne
depuis le 12 octobre 2014 date de sa
fermeture définitive
la maison d'arrêt d'orléans accueilli
depuis 1896 des milliers des milliers de
détenus
des hommes des femmes et des mineurs
avant sa destruction complète prévue
dans quelques mois la mairie d'orléans
qui a acheté le bâtiment à l'état
organise des visites aux orléanais qui
le souhaitent à l'intérieur l'atmosphère
pesante est palpable
un filet de sécurité et des longs
couloirs bordés d'innombrables cellule
105 places officielles jusqu'à 300
détenus
certains visiteurs n'en avaient pas
forcément conscience qu'est ce qui vous
choque le plus finalement à la
promiscuité puis les cellules très petit
le manque de place d'autres prennent des
photos c'est important pour vous d'avoir
un souvenir oui je sais pas si on peut
vraiment parler de souvenirs mais en
tout cas de venir voir l'endroit où ont
pu vivre des gens pendant 2 ou 5 ans
c'est important d'avoir une pensée pour
ces gens qui ont été enfermés dans un
espace aussi petit et restreint avec une
privation des libertés direction
l'extérieur là aussi les lieux sont
séparés il ya la cour des hommes avec un
terrain multisports la cour des mineurs
vous pouvez observer différentes choses
ont déjà pour s'évader il faut le
vouloir parce que elle entièrement donc
que ce soit mûr et soit grillagé au
sauver des enfants et puis il y à la
cour réservée aux femmes qui pouvaient
recevoir leurs enfants un lieu un peu
plus chaleureux si l'on peut dire
il reste encore un peu de vie d'ailleurs
une mosaïque colorée sur un mur c'est le
côté on va dire vive entre guillemets
les couleurs vous trouve que ça a un
côté un peu plus ensoleillés rame entre
guillemets imaginer que des femmes sont
venues enfin à cohabiter ici et le fait
que les enfants soient venus également
c'est assez c'est pesant
la maison d'arrêt d'orléans objet de
toutes les curiosités
près de 2000 personnes ont eu ce
privilège
dans deux ans il y aura un centre
aqualudique à la place de cette antienne
prison pour un coût de talent d'environ
20 millions d'euros